so just a little bit about me and about
me and our mock down so to be honest I
never touch our until last year March
and what happened so when I was in Grant
our College so I used to go and see and
then I did some numerical analysis using
MATLAB and then once I got into a grad
program going to my ph.d program I
decided to do theoretical math so for
about six years the time that when I use
my computer is when I need to latex
stuff that's the only time that I need
to cold and then it's about time for me
to graduate right so I was like okay I
need to look for jobs and I first got
into the academic jobs and you know how
tough it is especially for pure
mathematician and then eventually I
realized okay I proper is not suitable
for academia it's definitely my problem
right so finally I saw that okay
data scientist it's the sesss job and I
need to make a living
then what happened so I had to go back
to review my statistics and then I
realized oh everybody's using R then I
had to learn it so I started using my
are while I'm taking some online courses
from Coursera and then I realized well
it's not really how imagine using R
because think about it I used to code in
C it's a low-level language there's no
something called packages and then I
turn into MATLAB and there's still not
something called packages and finally
when I use are I had to figure out what
packages I should use by googling and
reading things from Stack Overflow is
just frustrating
but then how I got into I'm knock down I
I was taking classes and all those
classes will require me to do report and
you know like assignments using amount
down you know to code up your stuff and
then also like explaining or the
graphics what you see from the data and
things like that and I realized well our
markdown has some features that I'm
familiar with because I can latex stop
and move over I can still close things
and then I can make it organized and
consistent so I got obsessed with our
markdown and that's why today I'm not
going to talk about my mathematical
thesis I'm going to talk about I'm right
down so my topic is less good or mac
down and fence for my SAS friend and
actually here make up the title and
ironically I'm not going to talk about
SAS and actually I'm trying to persuade
people to get away from SAS I'm going to
get into trouble because they're they
actually recording this so so I would
talk about how to use our markdown and
also version control to streamline the
model turbulence so let's take a look at
our line so now I call a job in Freddie
Mac I mean the modeling team and I'm a
modeler I need to do a lot of this
modeling stuff but moreover I also need
to do a lot of data analytics stuff
so from modeling like from end to end
workflow I will first talk about you
know in general how we think about what
would happen if we need to model
something right from end to end
I mean from pouring the data processing
the data and to adventure you've got
something into production and then I
would talk a little bit about what's the
current development process and its
challenges and then I will talk about
how we can improve this situation using
our markdown and version control and
finally I will show you guys a demo if
we have time and I'll make sure that it
will be fast because we have a happy
hour waiting for us okay so the general
model development were full so you know
I'm a mathematician so I like to just
like organize things step by step right
your math teacher always hired us
one is the step two is that so starting
from data extraction and then you do
some data analysis future engineering of
course you need to clean your data and
then pre-processing and then you will
decide okay what would be the model
algorithm I should use and what kind of
model that will fit into this situation
and then you would start implementing it
and then after that you will take a look
at you know what's the testing results
so that's postmodern analysis you need
to look at the model error and mover for
us you know in freddie mac you need to
be very careful with the model and we
need to do some sensitivity analysis we
do some scenario analysis where we would
have the home price suddenly drop right
you know what i mean by that and we also
need to look at the impact analysis
because that has something to do with
our security and if that doesn't work we
need to go back every works fine then we
let other team to do model validation
and they also like user acceptance
testing and then finally the big thing
documentation every single step we need
to document that and tell people that
why this model works and why we should
use it this is a very important thing in
the corporate environment and you can
see that like from someone who come from
academia this is just mind-blowing
and how much time that we actually spend
on documentation and then finally when
everything is fine we let model go into
production so it seems it's okay you
know this workflow very clear right
and also my company is a good company so
they provide a lot of tools so currently
what tools that I can use
so for programming tools of course sass
yeah
we need suss because we need to deal
with a lot of big data sets and then SAS
provide a nice server so we have a lot
of legacy code written in SAS you cannot
avoid it so SAS and then of course you
need to connect to database sequel and
of course we also have my open source
software or in Python and so on so fine
but we also need to do some data
analysis stuff right we need to do
reporting within two visualization and
we need to tell users why this model is
nice by showing them charts you don't
show them datasets you don't show them
numbers you show them charts so to do
charts we think for the thing the
Microsoft team we have excel we have
Word and of course I forget that I'm
using PowerPoint and of course we also
have my internal GUI applications
because we have lots of models that they
will touch each other they will just
interact with each other we use some of
the model our outputs from other models
and then we our output generated by our
models will also get used by other
models so we need to take a look at if
we change the model a little bit what
would be the impact or if other people
change their model will be their impact
to us so there's something we need to do
okay so assumes everything is fine but
what reality is is like this
so we have a lot of tools a lot of
platforms but there's some issue like
this like here it's like some of my cars
might be working in using sass a sequel
and do some data extraction you know
some model estimation because we need
the server for pic data but then some of
us may prefer to use open source
software or in Python and then we also
can do some testing of the model there
and then whatever these numbers come out
we need to transfer it to excel to
visualization and then we also need to
put them into the internal GUI
applications to look at this impact and
finally every single results go to word
because we need documentation we need to
document every single style
so speaking of this flowchart to be
honest it's kind of messy and most
important thing is like how can we
collaborate because remember when you're
in academia you're mainly working
probably like within a small team but
here you will get a lot of people
involved and every single step you need
to make sure you get it right so that
would prizes a lot of challenges if we
are now working in such a process so
will be the main challenges that we have
here so the first thing it's difficult
to keep track of any changes that you
have for your data and code so when
you're working by yourself you totally
know where you put your data which
version you're using and why you use
that but whatever you're working with
other people and how you share with them
you need to go back and forth and at
some point you probably just lose track
of which data you're actually using or
which code which version of the code
that you're actually using and then you
call it my use the wrong data may use
the wrong code to get the wrong results
and then you need to come back again and
see what happened so the second thing is
if it's hard to keep track of the data
of course we will have less control of
the data quality and you don't want to
fill in the wrong set of data to train
your model
and then also as unable to standardize
the estimation algorithms for each
product so think about in freddie mac we
do with fixed-rate mortgage 30 years 15
years 20 years and then adjust the rate
mortgages and all the other products
that you guys might get in real life and
we want to hold a core model that will
apply to every single product so that we
don't need to write every single product
its own set of model code but if we do
it this way then it's totally unable to
just standardize this coal because color
a might be doing this while color B
might be doing something different and
then they need to talk to each other and
it's just tough to keep track and of
course it's impossible to automate the
entire process then it takes time and
it's inconvenient for collaboration so
that's what I mentioned before if you're
working with a huge team or you know not
to be a huge team 10 people that how
you're going to make sure everybody's on
the same track right on the same page
and then it's hard to reproduce your
results and the finally it takes a long
time for documentation so we want to
reduce the time to do documentation so
that we can do more of modeling and
research but then if we need to do so
many copy and paste then also we need to
finally piece everything into one
documentation and we just takes a month
so to kind of reflect a little bit what
we actually need here for this process
so first of course we need a programming
platform that can standardize all our
code and then we need interactive
platform so that while we're coding we
can also see the graph and we can also
input text it's not just the comments
for the call but it's actuate
explanation and all these things you
know how you actually think about your
model and then how the model behave
while you are testing your model or your
training your model you can immediate
just put out all these text and then you
don't need to come back again while
you're documenting it and also we need a
centralized platform so that you can
reproduce your results everybody is
doing it at the same place but then
remember that we are sharing because
we're working in a team so finally we
need a shared platform with version
control so that everybody is using the
same code
same version of data and then that will
be for our collaboration
so it will be the ideal approach here we
say first we need an interactive and
centralized platform this platform
should be able to connect your database
because we need to do end-to-end model
process so we first pour data we'll be
able to connect to your database and
then we wouldn't be able to implement
code in different languages so people
might prefer our my preferred Python I
prefer sickled sorry no sass and then
also we hope that we can integrate with
the graphics and also tax so that we can
while we're doing all these model
testing stuff we can just generate our
graphics that's needed for the
documentation we can't just type in our
tests so that we can document everything
while we are doing the stuff and the
final we will should be able to hook up
with the internal core API so that we
can just push our output into internal
coil and easy to see that one with
impact if we change our model and all of
this we need to document them but
underneath most important thing is we
need a shared platform and under version
control so that everybody is on the same
page okay so let's talk about a solution
so if you are from academia I feel like
I'm just preaching to the choir and even
right now I feel like I'm free to
acquire now because everybody know that
okay the solution of course you need to
have something that's interactive coding
platform and there you need a version
control so from my experience excuse me
I started our since March last year and
then I got used to our markdown and then
finally I had the opportunity to join a
consortium to develop a course from Duke
and from that point I was starting
writing my first textbook for the course
using book down so that's a package on
top of our markdown and at that point
when after a joint Freddie Mac I was
like well can I actually use some of my
past experience to help so the first
thing I could think of is okay I need
our Mac them for interactive and
centralized platform so what I did is at
that point my team was busy with
documenting the model change and then I
proposed that okay what if I use a
markdown and I can't generate a template
for everybody so that everybody using
the same template and I created a cold
and then once you've just fit in the
data set it will automatically generate
all the table all the explanation and
all the graphics that are needed that's
the first step and then finally we can
just combine the entire whole thing
together into a whole document and then
we can send out now in my company we
have the version control that's get is
getting more mature
so we're thinking okay we want to
automate the entire process and we want
to do it from the model development
process post model analysis and also
finally we can synchronize the
documentation process at the same time
but then we need to get to do the
version control and we need to control
the conversion while we can still enable
the first ability for every teammate
there doing their own thing as long as
when they make any changes when they
push anything we know that okay which
version we're actually using
so here I want to show you guys a demo
so how I you know pretend that I'm
developing a model using book down so
that's a package built on top of our
mock down let me see what I can change
it here so a nice job from our studio
it's very easy for you to just like get
a book down project and then they'll
automatically give you a template of it
so here I have a demo
you know how I'm going to streamline the
model development I can show you guys
this is will be the final documentation
or final PDF file that I would generate
from this code and you can also find
this call from my github repository so
what I'm doing here is I'm trying to
just make a model documentation process
so first I will have an index file which
is easy and good thing for book down is
that once you separate all these are
markdown using the lumbering and then
they will automatically separate a
chapter for you so say for example like
I want to sorry it's just a little bit
messy here because I cannot just split -
oops so in this structure I have the
index file and there you can see that I
have some other markdown files laid out
over there so once you lumbering your
arm out and file the automatic or just
split the chapter for you so it's very
easy to finally combined into whole
thing as a PDF file so I try to do like
a small model to predict the results of
a English premium league game so I'm a
huge soccer fan so that's why I picked
this topic so the first thing well
then it's kind of tough for me because I
want to switch from the other markdown
file the first thing you need to do of
course you need to deal with the data so
my data is actually come from the cargo
European soccer database I process a
little bit so that we don't need to deal
with a huge database and I just pull out
the data that I need it is very small
sets of data so first you will need to
do some you know variable summary data
analysis say for example if I want to
see like will be the number of counts of
the shut ins for you know each situation
I have draw and loss and also win and
you see that like the majority is
actually in win and you can kind of tell
that this data is not a good data set
because if you actually look at the
numbers of the game results win you know
this class is like way more than the
other results like draw and loss and you
can kind of guess if I do a lot just
every question you know multi-class
logistic question and this is an
unbalanced data set and that model will
not be good so I'm not trying to tell
you guys how to do a model so please
forget about you know forgive me by you
know doing a lousy model here so then
let's go through the motor part and will
usually let it describe a methodology of
model will load our package so say for
example here I have a package dot R is
suppose that you know that's my model
implementation sorry the model
implementation cold and then it's like
written in a package and then I will
talk about okay what what explanatory
variables I'm going to use and then also
you know what method I'm going to use so
here I just use a very simple lasso
regularization model and then I will try
to use this model on different products
so the first case okay I want to focus
on the team Manchester United
so I will use this model and then just
like split the dataset that's you know
only Manchester United
and I trained it and I got some results
and then I report you know what the
model towers and all this kind of thing
and of course inspiring to stay here
eventually I will show the entire whole
PDF version and then suppose I might not
a colleague you know he or she is more
interested in not a team or another
product or he or she is responsible
doing that and then they can also like
do a separate product so the second case
this Liverpool and if you soccer fan you
probably understand why I pick these two
teams so suppose like you have another
colleague who is responsible for another
product and this card can just total
it's just like you know set up another
Amazon file and then these two will not
conflict with each other so you can
easily just like separate the workload
is enable more flexibility for
collaboration but then eventually when
you commit your changes use and get the
version control you will know that okay
you're calling making changes here and
then you making change here the two of
you will not conflict with each other
but then finally you will see the final
products let me go back to my PDF
version so here is my demo I have my
data and then this is my chapter 2
because chapter 1 is the introduction
and then I have my variable summary a
nice table you know explaining what
variable that I have in this data set
and then I was talking about like how I
split the train data and then testing
data some of the input variable analysis
and also the output variable analysis
and then finally when I got to the model
part so this is my next chapter and I
first talked about methodology that will
work for all different cases and then
I first talked about Manchester United
the model results well it seems like it
says if you won the Manchester United
would make a chore it only matters
whether it's a home game will wait game
so you see that the model is just
terrible and if you want to get a loss
it has something to do with whether the
team has some crosses but then - the
opponent teams cross this number of
crosses if you want to get a win you
should not fall so many and then what's
real say you should not also like pass
so many so the number of team crosses
you know have a negative parameter in
front of it and you should have more
possession so we probably know that
y-you know this season Manchester United
is not winning that many because they
are losing their possession and then
finally if you're in a very game and
you're probably like you know not in a
favour of winning and you see that right
next to it you can just piece these two
together using book down and that will
be the second case when you have
Liverpool and then it tells you that
under this model training there's no way
for you to get a drawer well which is
just just make sense and if you one
lever put you lose you're probably like
Liverpool should not just like it will
be you know negatively correlated with
the team crosses and also if they're in
a way game and then they will be more
likely to lose a game and then for
Liverpool to win it's also negatively
correlated to your team process which I
don't understand and then it would be
possibly correlated to the possession
time of the team so Liverpool right now
is on the third I believe in this season
so apparently you know they're doing
basically the same thing here so let's
get back a little bit of my slides
so there I did not show one thing is how
I coordinate you know the cooperation
music it it's because I just don't have
the Wi-Fi so I don't want to show that
part but usually what you can imagine is
in a git repository so suppose you have
multiple colleagues working together for
one project then you can put all your
model code package and also
documentation template into the master
branch and so then you can set up
different branches like Manchester
United and then you will have one
colleague call you know Elissa quoi
working on that branch and then she can
just like change whatever she like and
feel like okay for this particular data
set for this particular case how I can
you know change my model and then you
will have another colleague working for
another branch called Liverpool and then
this lizard wall which is like you know
try to come up with a different set of
parameters that will work particularly
for Liverpool so now everybody know how
to find me on Facebook and Gmail and
please don't hack my accounts okay
so I've talked too much and let's do a
summary so we say that in the current
modeling process we use multiple
programming and reporting tools but
they're not necessarily integrated so
that will take us more time to actually
do this redundant work so the lack of
interactive coding platform version
controls creates difficulties also
challenges in you know tracking the code
and data changes how to standardize your
code and how to reproduce a results and
also like it's inconvenient for
collaboration and of course it's
impossible to automate this entire
process so our markdown together would
get we provides the ideal solution
involving interactive and centralized
platform and with version control so
that it's much easier and you can also
sync rifice the documentation process
while you're actually doing your
modeling ok so thank you very much
you